talking about this musician aspect of
your life and what you did with the show
and all the success you've had you said
there's a couple that have gotten away
uh from you and the one person you
always mention is Paul Simon and me too
I've always wanted to interview Paul
Simon to me what a great songwriter if
his music isn't the greatest
I mean I just I adore him and that for
me the the reason that
we wanted to that I really really wanted
to do it is my my first or earliest
experience of like singing in a car so
we always used to go on a holiday me my
sisters my mum and dad we used to go on
vacation to a trailer in Bournemouth
which is on the south coast of the UK
this was not a great holiday we'd be on
a trailer on a farm uh and one year it
we went for two weeks and it rained
torrential rain and on day 10 my mum
said we're gonna go home and the next
thing she said to my dad next year and
all my friends everybody used to go
abroad by this point people started
going abroad in Europe and these other
decisions next year we're going abroad
so we then would drive so we drive from
our house to the coast which was about
three hours we'd then go overnight or on
or of the whole day on a ferry
but you know you part of the ferry and
then we drive
nine or eleven-ish hours to the south of
France it sounds hard right there well
and and in many ways he was it was
however they are some of my most joyous
memories and the particular album of
those road trips was Graceland
um my mum would just be asleep
and the four of us would just sing every
single word and like that's there's a
he's got there are lyrics on Graceland
and obviously all of his music but for
me that album I think might be perfect
and there's the one thing you know
that's on gum boots where he's got a
lyric where he says you don't feel you
could love me but I feel you could which
I think
sums up how any
sort of stereotypically unattractive boy
at the age of 14 or 15 feels about every
girl at their school at the time you
don't feel you could love me but I feel
you Curt it's so optimistic and we're so
brilliant about it we've all lived that
you know we've all lived there and he
sums it up in one sentence one line in
one line how who hasn't said that to God
and they've said I like you but as a
friend you say you don't feel you could
love me but I feel you could and so I
had this idea where I was like I would
just give anything to drive around in a
car with Paul Simon and I had this idea
that I would maybe try and surprise my
mum and dad and my sisters and that we'd
all get in this car and sing the song
but uh yeah no Paul um
yeah like you say it's difficult it's
hard to get he's hard to get and as he
should be you know